done minimalists
maxims.com all right carol's got a
question what does a truly healthy
friendship look like i have a pithy
answer
for you i think let me just be clear
about this because
we have to be careful with the word
healthy quite often we use that
to say good like what is a good
relationship
and if by good you mean fulfilling
that's one thing we use good as just
sort of this placeholder word
but unfortunately we often mean good as
in like morally good
yeah and i will just say that there
aren't morally good or morally bad
relationships
if someone's harming you then they are
being you know
they're creating they are creating these
immoral indiscretions
and so that's something different but if
we're talking about a healthy
relationship here's my pithy answer for
you
a healthy relationship is one that
enhances your life
without trying to change the other
person
um you know we often say ryan you can't
change the people around you
but you can change the people around you
meaning
i can't say well ryan i really think
that you you should cut your arm off it
would really make me happy if you cut
your arm off right
right away and no instead it's like well
i
i can start to surround myself that's
really what's going to make me happy i'm
going to have to go search for people
who have one arm right right as opposed
to trying to sever off my best friend's
arm yeah of course that's a ridiculous
perotic
exaggeration but what it does is it
illustrates a point
instead of changing someone in my life i
can surround myself with
supportive caring people also i found
this
other definition here that that really
stood out to me
this is gal emma krebs she has a podcast
called the curious one i know about it
because bex was on her podcast recently
and so was our friend colin wright
i told her i would do episode 100 of her
podcast which i think she's about 50
episodes away from
so she has something to work toward but
the curious one podcast this is from her
instagram account at the curious
one podcast and she took a the
screenshot i think it is a reworking of
dr
nicole lapera's thoughts on relationship
and here it says
relationship noun a safe space to evolve
through life together let's break that
down for a second
so a safe space to evolve through life
together so a healthy relationship
ryan's in my relationship orion and
mariah's relationship for example
it is a safe space meaning it's there is
no it's not about tension or judgment if
i'm
if i commit some sort of act or
indiscretion or error
it's not about your judgment of me if i
do need help and i ask for help you'd be
willing to help me i know that
but it's not about changing that other
person that's what that safe space
is about evolving through life together
means that
as you change your relationship changes
as well
uh beck's on her podcast how to love and
i we're having this conversation
about there isn't really a relationship
so much as there's two people who are
constantly evolving and as we
travel on the same path together like
when you and i live with colin for that
year in missoula like we were very
closely on that same exact path
for a year but then his path sort of
bifurcated from
hours and for a period of time but of
course
they may come back together at some
point as well
and so a relationship doesn't have a
defined
period of time it's what is going on
right now and as we
change the quote-unquote relationship
changes
as well yeah it's interesting because
that definition
has the word evolve right yes and
evolution is changing
right so you're not trying to change
someone you are
trying to support them in their changes
that's a great way to put it
uh my pit the answer is this there are
three main
ingredients in a healthy relationship
love respect and understanding
and and how to uh i'm sorry and uh uh
love people use things
there is a recipe in there that we have
for a healthy relationship and i think
uh there are eight ingredients
in there that's right so there are
certainly more ingredients than love
respect and understanding but i know
that this is my context whenever i start
to
find myself uh
like having a having a knee-jerk
reaction or getting a little upset or
whatever it is
with with any of my relationships
romantic friendships
or even like a colleague it's like i
have to go back to okay if i want
to not if i want if i want to
de-escalate whatever's happening right
now inside of me
then i have to focus on this context of
love respect and understanding because
even when you go meet someone for the
first time you go order a coffee
you know when you're when you're talking
to the barista all they want is they
want to see that a
you respect them b that uh you know you
have some
type of understanding where they're
coming from and that you're being a
genuine
loving kind person like you can never go
wrong with that right so if
if any of those i will say if any of
those three ingredients are missing from
the relationship
it's probably not going to be maybe it
said the healthy we say meaningful it
wouldn't be a very meaningful
relationship if you're missing uh one of
those three ingredients
i i agree with that and so yeah there
are eight ingredients i'll just go
through those real quick there's a
section in
a lot of people use things called
repairing and strengthening
relationships and it talks about the
eight different
ingredients here ryan and i pinpointed
the eight elements of great
relationships
of meaningful relationships and if i
were to characterize those elements
today i'd define them as
follows and so i'm not even going to
read through all the definitions but we
have love so you mentioned that
you have trust honesty
and so trust and honesty are slightly
different and that's why they're both in
here
caring support attention
authenticity and understanding and then
we
break down understanding which has like
four main ingredients respect is one of
those ingredients and that's
that's sort of the third ingredient and
i like what you say to ryan about
the three main ingredients because like
if you make your famous masaman curry
there might be three main ingredients
but there's going to be more than three
ingredients uh that are important for a
meaningful relationship yeah like the
masaman curry
actually it's it's funny uh because just
to continue the analogy
there are several ingredients just in
that curry
that have to come together right to make
the masaman curry so and that could be
the like understanding so
understanding is tolerance acceptance
respect and then appreciation that's how
you truly
understand someone you you awaken
to that person when you're able to
appreciate them warts and all
now ryan i do want you to talk about
real quick the de-escalating because
you mentioned that if if because
de-escalating is an
important part of meaningful
relationships
so why would someone want to de-escalate
in a relationship
uh you don't always when you hear that
you don't always associate that with
relationships
yeah if you're escalating tension
or you know an argument or whatever it
is in a relationship you are
pushing that person further away and
the more you escalate the more you're
gonna push which is gonna lead to
uh resentment it's gonna lead to
sometimes it'll lead you feeling guilty
for pushing that person away i mean it
leads to all types of negative emotions
and unfortunately it'll eventually lead
to a toxic relationship
yes so de-escalating is going to
be the hardest thing to do especially if
you're in the moment
and you're very heated and you're very
angry and you feel
disrespected it's it's very
uncomfortable to de-escalate however in
the long run like that's going to be
your best option
anytime you're 99.99 of the time
uh that you know you're getting into an
argument
i want to talk about respect a little
bit because a lot of people
they have the expectation of they need
to be respected
and you know the you know oh that
so-and-so is disrespect it was
disrespect to me and i'm gonna you know
i'm gonna disrespect them back
but the thing is is like in order to be
respected
you have to respect others that's how
you earn it that's how you're in respect
is by respecting others you don't walk
into a situation
demanding respect and then all of a
sudden
you base your actions off of whether or
not that person
is respecting you if they start to
disrespect you a little bit
if anything you should go again to
de-escalate go out of your way
to respect them because that's the only
way you're actually going to get them to
uh well understand yes where you're
coming from
i want to talk real quick about
attention as well and then we can maybe
wrap up by talking about toxic
relationships yeah what is a toxic
relationship we can try to
define that a bit but attention is this
fascinating thing because
that is one of the eight elements that
we we covered there
for a meaningful relationship
unfortunately
it we can have misguided attention
another way to think of attention is
focus
right so if you focus on on something
you may be focusing on the quote unquote
wrong thing of the relationship
yeah someone everyone has their quirks
and foibles and
and idiosyncrasies and your partner or
friend or family member might do one
thing that drives you insane and if you
focus on that then you're not you're
actually getting in the way of your
overall awareness of the person uh what
do you think about that is attention
is a spotlight and
uh awareness is a floodlight
and so having awareness of the overall
relationship with the other person
and seeing them for who they are not who
you
hope they will become who you think they
should
be yeah which by the way is toxic
behavior trying to change someone
that is a type of of violence sometimes
not physical
violence but the change you know
it's violent the same way an earthquake
is violent
it's not physically harming you directly
although it can indirectly harm you
but it is forcing the change
upon you that is
that's frustrating and what it does then
that attention think about the word
attention
at tension and so if we're just paying
attention
to all of those things that drive us
crazy about the relationship
of course it's bubbling up this tension
inside us as opposed to that awareness
if there's full open-hearted awareness
for the relationship
then there's a type of respect but also
appreciation for the other person and if
you're able to get there
then you're able to truly understand
them and no matter what they do
they cannot harm you because who told
you that you're supposed to be
respected who told you that you're
supposed to be
loved no no you're not supposed to be
anything if someone loves you that's
fine if not that's fine too
but as ryan said back in the corporate
days it was sort of like
you know i'm going to force these people
to be my friend
and it's like well if i'm forcing you to
be my friend
are you am i really your friend i
remember i was like so heartbroken one
time when
i thought you know this it was an
employee of mine too
like it wasn't even like we weren't even
like colleagues in the sense as
like he worked for me and i just
remember
i forget what i've asked him to do
something like to hang out or something
he's like no dude
he's like i don't he's like no i have my
own life at home
i just remember being like you do
what's that like right and so that's a
type of solipsism right solipsism says i
am the center of the universe
and the thing is we're all solipsistic
in that way because
we all in our heads unless we stop and
have that awareness
that we talked about a moment ago unless
we have
an open-hearted open-eyed awareness for
the world and the people and the things
around us
then all of a sudden it's all about me
and i get it it makes sense because
it's my attention is always
emanating from my consciousness it's me
watching my television looking at my
phone
reading my book drinking my
water and so of course that's our point
of view what awareness does allows us to
step back and say
okay that's an illusion you could call
it the illusion of self or
but it's an illusion that i am
the center of the universe and if you
realize that that's an illusion then all
of a sudden
the i am suffering or i am angry or i am
upset or i am tense is also an illusion
tense attention is appearing
anger is appearing and no one has
permission
to make you angry you are making
yourself angry in every
relationship and it's really hard for us
to deal with that and even now like
sometimes people make me angry but do
they really yeah
it's like if the rain comes through and
rains all over your picnic ryan
was the rain angry or are you angry is
the rain upset or are you
upset well you made that decision either
consciously or
unconsciously to be upset by it the
world goes on
with or without your reactive emotion to
it
and so whoever told you that
you are whoever told you that
you're supposed to be respected or loved
or anything else no
no those are ingredients for a
meaningful relationship
but you also have to earn those
ingredients by
reciprocating well the best way to
reciprocate is to do it in advance
yeah can we talk about toxic
relationships what is a a toxic
relationship
i have a loose definition i want to talk
to you about because i think this word
is often sort of it's been overused and
vap vapidized over the the last decade
or so we see it all the time now talking
about
toxic relationships but for me a toxic
relationship is
one that tries to change me
and or one that pressures me
so it's either abusive that's a type of
of pressure
it could be physical abuse emotional
abuse or it can just be passive
aggression
right that that is that is also toxic
behavior so i really
look at those three ingredients there's
some sort of of uh abuse
there is uh the passive aggressive
nature or
someone is trying to change me
unfortunately we try to change people
all the time yeah
you know what that's like ryan that's
like if uh say i
go to the doctor because i've got ulcers
in my stomach right and i'm like oh
doctor can you prescribe
some medicine for my neighbor for my
best friend because i have ulcers in my
stomach
and he'd be like yeah sure i'm like oh
great now i feel better because
now i'm giving him i'm changing him with
this medicine well no no i need to look
inward and change whatever's going on
with me
the prescription is not for someone else
i don't need to fix you ryan i simply
need to
readjust the way that i'm interacting
with the world did you enjoy this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel
100 advertisement free